hello folks and welcome to
rational science the only site on the
internet that does
physics right and i hope all of you are
doing fine today
today we're going to be doing a little
bit of uh geometry we're going to be
looking at a
misunderstood figure known as the
triangle but before i get to that i want
to talk about
extinction i had lots of questions and
comments on extinction
and apparently it's a quite popular
subject
and i can't answer all the questions for
sure but
i do what i can here okay so here let me
start it with this
i receive this in my email okay
and it's uh says that i won the lottery
to
to become a a us resident
i guess these people didn't know who
they send it to
and what i really get out of this is
that this shows
how close we are to extinction we have
all these scams
everywhere on the internet that's what
people do for a living these days they
they just do scams
and it just uh makes you wonder you know
um
you have companies set up and they hire
people to to just call you on the phone
or send you a message or whatever
all that scamming gives you an idea that
you know there is no work out there
and so people have to do scamming as and
essentially what we're all doing or a
lot of people out there doing
is living off the fat of the land of
what
our forefathers created and bequeath to
us
and all these people are just living of
that wealth okay
that's still around but right now you
know we're not creating new wealth
not not at the rate as we used to create
it
around the planet okay um
here's one fella who says that i'm
skipping over the extinction part
of my video the last time right
because bill's opinions are just that
uh poor fellow he doesn't uh know the
difference between
a theory and an opinion an opinion is
religion
okay that's what it is okay and uh we're
not talking about
opinions here we're talking about a
theory
some people say that uh the dinosaurs
for example died because an asteroid hit
the earth
other people say that in the permian the
animals in those days died because of
volcanic activity
if you go to the ordovician they say
well those guys died because
there was a supernova and i'm saying
that they all died all of them
because uh there was an economic
collapse
what collapsed was their food
disappeared and when their food sources
disappeared
first gradually you know you have fewer
and fewer species because they have
fewer and fewer niches to occupy
and then also not only do you have fewer
varieties but you also have few uh less
volume
and so those animals eventually at some
point crash they go
away and a new food chain emerges
and that's the theory am i asking you to
believe the theory
no that's my proposal see i can talk
about the theory of
relativity that doesn't mean i believe
in it i'm just exposing a theory
and i try to to present it
objectively that's what science is about
and this person
believes it's an opinion no it's not an
opinion it's a theory it's called a
theory it's called an explanation
okay okay another fellow says
dinosaurs are a hoax
[Laughter]
he thinks that these are old whale and
elephant bones
cobbled together for the amusement of
the crowds
those things that you see there okay
well let's find out here uh
uh you know a short while ago they
discovered
the um skeleton uh the whole skeleton
really of uh
king richard iii and here here he is
this is what he looks like
and uh they reassembled it and they were
able to
tell that yeah that was the body of uh
of uh richard iii because they looked at
some of his descendants and they had the
same
dna okay or similar dna they were able
to
confirm that this was the guy and they
found him at bosworth field there you
know
and uh so they can they can take a
a skull for example and
because of that they can say okay this
is more or less what this person looked
like it doesn't have to be exact but you
can
more or less get a picture of what this
person looked like in real life
okay and that's what they do they you
know you have these artists that
study facial features quite
in quite a bit of detail and they are
able to reassemble
you could say you know reconstruct uh a
face in fact uh
you know you have all these um medical
examiners and forensic uh
people and they do that a lot to solve
crimes
okay and so here's uh
here's this uh uh you find this in the
rock
okay find these big heads
uh these skulls uh are those elephant
skulls or whale skulls
what are those uh maybe an old rhino
that died is that what a rhino looks
like
and uh you can see that uh you know
you're not gonna be able to relate those
skulls with any
animal alive today whether whale or
um or uh
what is it uh or or uh
elephant or rhino for that matter right
so yeah you you uh you know it's it's
nice to
say these things but uh
you know again what i think these people
are is just religious people
uh who uh don't uh
don't like their theories uh
give me a second here they don't like um
to be able to uh have their religion
trashed
and they have these beliefs and when
they see something like that they just
turn their heads away and they say well
i'm not gonna look at that
i don't believe in that it's like saying
you're looking at black and you're gonna
call it white
that's more or less what these people
are doing okay
anyways uh another uh individual says
went to the other side in a second here
from the bottom
says your observation that humans have
low genetic diversity i think you are
working with faulty data
there indeed with billions of humans on
the planet you're bound to have a large
measure of genetic diversity
particularly with the large migrations
going on
spreading mutant or rare genes
this vowel knows very little about
genetic diversity obviously
depending on how you define genetic
diversity humans are practically
identical to chimpanzees
what you measure is what you get uh
no uh absolutely not here's an article
okay and this came out
a few years ago and there was a couple
studies in fact this is just one of them
where they did in fact uh compared
chimps
and they took a troop maybe 50 to 100
chimps
uh in africa in some country in africa
and uh they found that just uh these 50
to 100
individuals chimps had more genetic
diversity than the entire human race
listen to that you know just a small
group had more genetic diversity in the
entire than the entire
human race and uh you say how can that
possibly be
you would think it's the other way
around and
again you know uh people are mistaken in
their notions of
genetic diversity of of what it means
and what it entails and how it got there
okay
uh obviously they didn't they don't do
much of a research
on these subjects okay and they just
have these beliefs
okay and here's a study on uh famous
amish
uh who've been inbreeding for the last
300 years
and uh they're having all kinds of
problems
and they're traceable to the founder
effect the fact that
they had few people from where all the
population today of amish descent
okay they descend from a very small
group of people
in the hundreds and here we have
hundreds of thousands
today okay there's i think 350 000 amish
in the region
ohio indiana pennsylvania you know that
whole amish region
and they all descend from essentially
the same
uh founders okay and that have been
inbreeding for so long a time and that's
why they study these groups because
they're like
isolated communities and they're having
all kinds of problems or
like you see there they're having the uh
the six fingers
uh people they have a thumb and
five fingers okay and here's an analysis
of what genetic diversity is
uh more or less this is a synthesis
okay the three major forces shaping the
genetic variation
in the present amish population are
genetic drift
recombination and mutation okay
because of their unique ances ancestral
history
a modest number of founders account for
all genetic variation present in the
current
uh old order amish population as a
consequence while many
rare variants entering the population on
only a single founder chromosome
have become lost others have increased
in frequency through
genetic drift and can be found at
appreciable frequencies in the current
population
okay so what's going on with the uh with
the amish
is that because they've been in breeding
for so long they lost genetic diversity
they don't have any diversity within
their community and so
uh you know the because of this
essentially this inbreeding process
that's been going on for so long they're
having problems with
children that are born today okay and
yeah
that's one theory other people might
have a different idea about it
i'm just telling you what my conclusion
is from this and from the studies that i
looked at
and i put that in my book okay here's uh
what i put in my book i put what
what i call the law of genetic diversity
and what this uh law of genetic
diversity
is that um essentially you know
after a species is born in other words
when it comes out of the
mother trunk and gets isolated
and they start reproducing at first
because they encounter new environmental
uh conditions uh their
which selects their genes their genetic
diversity increases but then after that
you know what happens as long as they
continue inbreeding and more so when
they're they become sedentary what
happens
is they lose their genetic diversity
and i think that's what's happened to
the
amish i think that happened also to the
neanderthals if you check
a lot of studies that's been done on the
neanderthals
they discovered that they didn't have
much genetic diversity at all
and and the genetic diversity started
falling
falling from about 80 000
years ago to about 40 000 years ago the
upper paleolithic so uh i think there's
a trend
uh between genetic diversity inbreeding
and time and you can only lose genetic
diversity after that you can never
recover it we humans we cannot recover
our genetic diversity there's nothing we
can do about it
uh we can't sleep with a chimp you might
say well we can tailor it
um technologically you know with some
kind of uh
thing in the lab uh good luck okay i
don't know what they're gonna turn you
into
because the more they change the the
less human you become
and so again uh we're like the end of
the line
and this is how humans end you know with
whatever
genetic variation we have you know in
our populations
that's it okay uh
another fellow says says technology
raising the issue of technology
technology is a double-edged sword and
i'm sure
uh could just as likely cause the crash
in food availability you know
availability
you posit this is something we don't
have what
evidence that's what they think about
evidence
from past extinctions uh to work with
yeah i don't think you're gonna find too
much technology in the dinosaurs okay
so it's not too much it's not that you
won't find
any technology we're the only real
uh animal that has mammal especially
that has used technology in any
uh meaningful way you know all the
others essentially
just do food some of them you know like
beavers they build houses
and so on you could say that there is
some a level of technology
somewhere in the animal kingdom but
essentially we're
it that's it okay and then uh he goes
into again the
notion that people have that all these
are catastrophic events he says
uh extinction level events can be ruled
out
uh can't be ruled out if the yellowstone
super volcano erupts it would wipe out
american grain production and
allied to the fragile nature of the
world's food economy cause
and i guess an extinction event uh
yeah uh again these people think that
it's it's
uh it's all catastrophic and it has
nothing to do with catastrophes it has
to do with our economy at least my
theory
so he says that's kind of a hybrid
version of your theory
thesis no absolutely not mine has
nothing to do with climate change which
is one of the ones he mentions down
there
it has nothing to do with technology has
nothing to do with disease
has nothing to do with asteroids strikes
or any catastrophe for that matter
it has to do with the disappearance of
food
in the case of humans food disappears
why because
money disappears and without money no
one produces or distributes food
that's in a nutshell the theory you can
look up some of my videos there it goes
into more detail
but it's when people introduce this
climate change and technology and they
get all confused
because they think that's what i'm
talking about that somehow they can fit
that
in and it's not true it's uh none of
these have anything to do with my theory
my theory says that food disappears
humans disappear
it's as simple as that why will food
disappear because money disappears
why will money disappear well that's a
long story and that's another issue that
someone uh raised here so let me wait
for that
and this fellow says humans when their
abstract concept meaning money i guess
disappears they starve themselves and go
extinct
i'll be over here growing my own food
and free of
vacs and morons
uh so all i can put is uh bob dylan's uh
song talking world war iii blues he said
hey i've been having the same old dreams
but my world is a little different you
see
i dreamt that the only person left after
the war was me
i didn't see you around not in my dream
right
well now uh time passed and now it seems
everybody's having them dreams everybody
sees themselves walking around with
nobody else no one else uh yeah that's
more or less everybody thinks he's gonna
be the one who survives
and see nobody around them and yeah i
guess
uh it's very hopeful i hope uh you've
taken all the precautions for that right
looked ahead right but of course if you
don't believe that humans are gonna
become
extinct then you don't do anything about
it it's just as simple as that
okay and uh here's uh one fella and he
says he's the pho i was talking about a
minute ago
and he says the father says do you need
money for food
property kills go figure uh did you mean
no money for the rich
or did you mean money for the rich and
lust for the poor
but then he asked the right question and
that's the question everybody wants
answered
at least from me because that's my
theory he says
what is the mechanism that leads to no
money
uh yeah that's uh
a long talk there the process
i have to write it up
all i can tell you is that uh the theory
is that money will disappear and yeah
people want to know
what is the process that leads to the
extinction of money
why will man stop trading essentially
that's what it comes down to okay
and that's a long process it's it
happens in a very short time but
you got to look at each one of the
frames in the movie
okay you got to look at each frame in
the movie to what happens here and there
and in the other place and you got to
look at the whole planet
okay and you gotta look at the economy
of the entire planet
and all i can tell you right now in
general terms is
the human economy cannot grow forever
more so when population doesn't grow
forever and population cannot grow
first because it's right now growing
asymptotically
our birth rate for the global global
birth rate
is declining okay that's one issue and
without
population you have no demand without no
demand you have
no business it business starts leveling
off
they start shutting companies down or
merging
and laying off workers and which is more
or less the process we see today
but that's in general terms i would have
to go into a lot more detail
and that takes a whole uh
video the whole
lecture okay uh here's uh one fellow and
he says
uh this graph shows the number of
species
which is different from the amount of
biomass i put this
graph the other day the crotest
cretaceous terrestrial revolution
and what you see there is a big red blot
and what that red part of the graph
is are the angiosperms the flowering
plants and you can see that for the lab
for half of the cretaceous
they displaced uh all the other species
but what this vowel says is those are
not the amount of
biomass he's saying those are just a
number of species that's what he's
clarifying
yeah those are the number of species but
keep in mind that
you know those species multiply not only
in quant
in variety but also in quantity and so
the
the issue is that yeah the the
angiosperms did these uh displace the
gymnosperms why because uh by the time
you get to the quaternary
uh you don't see conifers and today we
have
a few conifers on the planet so
something changed
so not only were there more varieties
but there were more of them as well
more volume okay anyways
this fella says uh the lack of diversity
in our food supply is a threat to human
existence we might counter that
by selectively breeding plants in a
range of laboratory controlled
conditions
again these people think this is an
issue of technology
that we go to the lab and uh
and you know just do some kind of
experiment
produce new varieties and it will be
okay
this is uh what i'm proposing is in
economic collapse
no one's going to go to the lab because
you got to pay the guy who goes to the
lab if there's no money
because they're they're the whole
economic system of man has collapsed
and no one's going to go to any lab no
one's going to do any study everybody's
just going to look for food
that's what happens when the global
economy collapses so this notion that
we're just going to develop
new breeds of plants by injecting them
with some kind of
dna or whatever uh yeah they're doing
that even today but it doesn't mean
we're going to
that's going to save us what's the
problem here is not a question of
quality it's going to be a question of
volume
okay we're not going to have the volume
of food okay and uh
this is uh who who wrote a book
his name is uh robert baker and i do
recommend this book
okay i read it twice uh i like it so
much
uh and i don't agree with much of what
uh robert baker says but the book is
a very good book partly because
it's a book about science it's a book
about
theories and that's what i love about
that book
it's about theories you don't have to
believe in the theories but the guy
gives it a good crack
and he says uh you know that he's going
to be talking about different theories
and just about
every chapter is about theories and he
also has a lot of
facts because he's a guy who's worked in
the field
as a paleontologist okay so um
i do recommend it he says there you know
that
that process there that uh
the animals come in there they ate for
example the cycads
and so they wiped them out and now what
happened next was the
angiosperms grew in that place
and now that plant disappeared now you
have a new plant
that has taken that squatted that piece
of land
and now you multiply that times volume
times time
and over time then yes what you'll see
is displacement
of the foods that
the dinosaurs ate the cycads and
other conifers and what displaced them
were the
angiosperms my theory on that is that
the dinosaurs did not eat angiosperms
there's been a couple studies that says
that they did i do not
subscribe to those theories i'm saying
that the dinosaurs grew with conifers
just like we
grew with angiosperms we do not eat
conifers we do not eat
um ferns okay and so
uh you know it's not like we can switch
overnight and say well
oh there's no lettuce anymore no uh no
apples
i think i'm gonna eat ferns from now on
no
it doesn't happen and it doesn't happen
with us and it doesn't happen with the
animals either with
the rest of the animal kingdom animals
get used to a certain type of food
forever
especially like you know in the case of
the dinosaurs
they got used to conifers that's all
there was at one point in time
and then uh right behind them you know
like i saw in the you show
i showed in the graph there uh the
angiosperms came right behind and
sneaked up on them and started growing
all over the planet
as far as the dinosaurs were concerned
all those were weeds
yeah they didn't eat weeds they didn't
eat um angiosperms
and so when the conifers were
essentially you know the forest of
cycads essentially uh uh
became smaller and smaller became small
islands that's when the dinosaurs
disappeared
that's that's my theory on that in
general terms okay
okay final comment on uh extinction here
uh fellow says uh invokes
herodotus uh who was uh historian
ancient historian days of the greeks and
i
had to put the first line there because
he missed that you just put the darker
blue there
and it says this is what errata said he
says
these are the stories of the persians
and phoenicians
for many states that were once great
have now become
small and those that were great in my
time were small before
knowing therefore that human prosperity
never continues in the same place
i shall mention both alike that's more
or less how he starts his book
okay histories and um
yeah he's right but see the notion that
china which is the context here that
china is going to replace the united
states
as the next empire now history will not
repeat itself
in the last generation on earth china
has no
chance of surpassing the united states
because today we have a global economy
something of persians and phoenicians
did not have
so we have a different world today okay
so you cannot just uh extrapolate
ancient history and say well there's
always been new empires and old
empires collapse and that's what's going
to happen in the future not anymore
this is it this is the end the buck
stops here why because what's going to
happen here
is that the americans will not allow
a country like china surpassed them
because they know what the consequences
of that are and right now uh the united
states is
kind of nervous because they had quite a
bit of losses
last year in both jobs and companies
and the chinese came up and caught up a
little more not that they caught up but
they're catching up you know they're
coming up
not only in economics but militarily as
well and in
political influence around the world and
respect and so all that stuff right
and so the united states is not going to
allow that and they're going to do
whatever it takes to
uh stop china and it can't stop china
from growing but that might lead to a
war
very likely like mr kissinger i heard
the other day say uh
this resembles very much what happened
just before world war one
you know that saber rattling and i think
something like this is going to happen
right here as well it can happen at
least if it does happen i just hope they
keep it to a conventional war
okay or like i think it was einstein who
said uh i don't know how the third world
war will be fought but i know how the
fourth one will be it'll be
fought with sticks and stones
okay let's move on from extinction to
the triangle okay and as an introduction
to the triangle
uh again i'm gonna pull up some of the
questions or comments people made
okay because that's going to drive us
into
what the problem with the triangle
really is the ultimate problem the
underlying problem okay
okay so let's start with the um uh
with the uh first one which is this
okay uh fellow says
essentially he copied this from uh from
the wikipedia
verbatim an experiment is a procedure
carried out to support refute or
validate a hypothesis
okay so what is this fellow talking
about
well he's uh talking about this
he's talking about something which the
question is whether it has anything to
do with science
if because support refute and validate
all those things have to do with opinion
with belief
an experiment has to do with evidence
with
creating evidence or generating evidence
or
you know eventually presenting this
evidence what why do we
create evidence what does a prosecutor
do with evidence
well his job is to persuade the jury
that's what experiments are used for
experiments are used for evidence and
evidence is just used to persuade
nothing more to convince yourself of
something
you could be the juror okay you could be
the guy who's trying to
convince himself or or either convince
yourself
or verify some theory that you have or
whatever
experiment has to do only with belief
only with belief there is no other
purpose for an experiment
therefore an experiment is not in itself
an objective
explanation of a mechanism okay
the only purpose of an experiment is to
target opinion belief
that means that it's going to be used to
persuade convince
convert and recruit and those are the
definitions of religion
religion is opinion believe persuading
convincing converting and recruiting
that's what religion is about okay
so uh no experiments evidence
has nothing to do at all with science
okay
and so here are uh the questions okay is
science about running an experiment
is science about observing is it about
making prediction
repeating the experiment to verify what
uh just to convince yourself collecting
data
describing with an equation is is that
what science is about
because this is what people think
science is this is what they've been
drilled to exhaustion to believe that
science is about running an experiment
um
observing you know verifying something
what is all that that's that all has to
do with belief
belief is of religion
so you know maybe the experiment
convinced you of something
the guy on the other side of the planet
he doesn't believe in the same thing
that you did
so who's right and then you do the
experiment in front of them and say but
here's the experiment the guy
continues to believe something else
so uh what have you proved to whom to
yourself
so you prove to a group of people and
these people now have the same religion
and the rest
uh believe in something else they have a
different religion
so who did you prove to so this is the
issue the issue is that science is not
about proof
science is not about experiments science
is not about evidence
let me prove it to you okay let me
present evidence so that i prove that
science
has nothing to do with experiments okay
let me do an experiment very expensive
experiment okay don't do this
very dangerous don't do this in without
an expert next to you a relative is the
patient okay
we have a pencil okay we let go of it
it falls to my table okay the table
wasn't there would fall to the floor
let's do it repeatable because all
experiments must be repeatable
okay the repeatable experiment we're
gonna do it twice now okay
there it goes fell to the floor this
time okay always falls down
you don't believe me do it at home let
just grab a pencil pen
whatever spoon let go of it you'll find
that it falls to the floor
what did we prove with the experiment
well what was the purpose of the
experiment what what what do you know
about gravity what do you know about
what
caused gravity to happen
okay that's the question here
and uh and here um
do you you know you can push your hand
uh wave your hand above it
you can wave your hand below it and
there's nothing there are no strings
there are no particles hitting it from
above
there are no strings pulling it from
below that you can detect or see
so the question is what has an
experiment told you
about the objects the things
that are coming in contact with the skin
of the pencil that's the question
what has come in contact with the skin
of this pencil
to make it fall down was there something
hitting it from above
was it something pulling it from below
what can you feel
or see okay below and above
what will an experiment tell you about
gravity for example
and uh and here's another experiment
okay
i always show this two little uh magnets
there okay
and uh you know any
you put them next to each other and you
have
um you what you have is uh attraction
and in fact you can see here i'm holding
it just barely and it's already pulling
it
it's already i'm trying to hold it apart
and it already
you know the green one goes to the red
one no matter what i do
and so the question is what is in
between these two magnets
can you see anything here or on the
outside can you see or touch
anything outside so the question is
what came in physical contact with these
two magnets that force them to come
together
that's the question that's where we
start and so for this you got to go to
the word
object you got to find out what a thing
is okay
and this is what we find okay
one fellow defines uh an object is that
which you can see or touch
and uh you will see this also in the
dictionary dictionary says an object is
that which you can touch or see or see
your touch okay
that's the notion people have it turns
out that they
have the same notion for the word exist
in other words for them the word exists
and the word
object are synonyms they say an object
is that which you can see or touch
and uh that exists is what you can see
or touch
so the it's a result of this that they
have
uh equated touch with um exist
with object they say these two things
are synonyms
okay and that's where the problem starts
because
if you think that an object is that
which you can see or touch
and you cannot see or touch what's
between these two magnets or outside the
two magnets
if you cannot see or touch what's above
or below the pencil
does that mean there's no object there
and that's what people have concluded
they've concluded that there is no
object because they cannot see or touch
it there's no
object that exists in there because they
can't see or touch it
and they equate object with existence
and so they say there's nothing
there what they don't realize is that
when they do that
what they're doing is filling that space
with spirits
they're saying gravity is done
with magic it's done with spirits with
angels black magic whatever
magnetism since you can't see or touch
the object there is no object there
and so what they do is fill the space
with spirits that's what they're doing
anyone who does not put an object there
and say there's no
object that came in contact with these
objects
is essentially uh putting a spirit in
there
it's doing black magic he's explaining
with black magic
and here we have a fellow and he defines
it
in a different way defines the word
object in a different way he got this
out of the
wikipedia again an object is an
identifiable
collection of matter okay so what are we
saying is that
that's a uh a bunch of apples is
an object a collection of matter is that
what it is
a collection of anything for that man
collection of trash is
is an object is that what these people
are saying
and uh says which may be constrained by
an identifiable boundary may
may or may not be like we don't care it
doesn't matter if it's got a
shape if it's got a boundary uh if it's
a collection of manner of a collection
of apples
we'll call that an object that's what
this fellow is saying that he just
copied it from the wikipedia without
analyzing what he copied
and he and you can see where he goes
with this he goes to visible intangible
the boundary is usually the visible or
tangible surface of the object
okay so he thinks that it's got to do
with tangibility
and with visibility he thinks that this
is a question of running an experiment
touching and seeing to prove the
existence
of the object which are synonyms the
existence and object are synonyms
and that's why he arrives at this
conclusion he says
if light is a massless particle massless
particle
i thought a particle was uh or uh
object was a collection of matter and
matters that which has mass according to
the wikipedia now he's saying that this
one has no mass
and two high energy beams interact then
you have a mechanism which occurred what
without an object he says that you can
do physics without an
object and there you have an example you
have all these lights crossing
all these beams of light crossing each
other and he's saying that light
you're staring at nothing that's nothing
he's saying there's nothing there and uh
if you look up uh in the in quora okay
here's what you'll find for uh for light
okay someone asks the question says
if light is a wave what is waving
a good question what is the these were
the different kinds of
uh answers that they got and there's
more of them there but you can look them
up look up that question in quora
and one guys it's the electromagnetic
field another guy says no it's the
electromagnetic wave
like if a wave is a field and the field
is a wave like they're synonyms right
the other guy says a wave is propagating
what energy
the other fellow says the answer is
space it's space that's waving
uh or nothing in other words and uh
another good fella says oh string theory
says that it's a string that's vibrating
and another follow finally says there is
no medium for light
so this these are the answers you get
after
what thousands of years of uh being
familiarized with light
and especially the last hundred years
since quantum mechanics was
invented you know these are the answers
these people give you and they're all uh
you know these these people say oh i'm
an expert i'm a physicist
physicist and this these are the answers
they give you they give you all whatever
they just put words in there and we
still don't know
what the answer is what is waving when
we talk about light
we need to identify what is wave what
physical object
these people are saying no we're going
to do without objects
we're going to do gravity without
objects nothing came in contact with a
pen it just
fell by magic nothing pushing it nothing
pulling it
because you know we can't see or touch
it and
an object is that which you can see or
touch and
when you have two magnets come together
there's nothing between them or outside
of them pushing them together because
again we can't see or touch them
whatever's there so the magnets just
came together by
magic just because they wanted to
you know we have no mechanism and these
people
do uh so-called physics with magic
with spirits they they're introducing
spirits they don't even know it
they don't they're not even aware of
that okay they introduce
words concepts such as field and wave
and so on then you say well what's a
field what's a wave it's the undulation
of nothing
there's nothing there so these are the
answers you get
okay so this takes me to uh my
conclusion for this little segment okay
the introduction
and this is it the principle of secret
agents
okay no experiment can elucidate
what an invisible intangible entity is
or looks like the only way to determine
what secret agents mother nature uses to
do gravity
light magnetism etc is through thought
experiments visualization you have to
think you have to
pull back and visualize what mother
nature could be doing
all these things with gravity light and
so on
and that's the only way you're going to
figure it out that's the only way you're
going to understand
how mother nature does her magic but if
you say there's no object there because
we proved it because we can't see or
touch anything in that region
then you're filling that same region
with spirits in black magic and just
walking away and saying well
i'm not going to deal with that question
anymore because i can't see or touch it
and what's an experiment going to show
you well if you can't touch it or see it
an experiment is not going to help you
very much that's
that's the conclusion okay
okay and so what does this have to do
with the triangle well it turns out that
the triangle
is a figure and a geometric figure
okay and the figure is the synonym of
the word object of the word thing
that's what a figure is because uh the
definition of the word
object figure thing is that which has
shape
so it doesn't matter which word you use
which synonym use that would test shape
okay and uh
so here um we have a triangle
okay for several of them and the
question is
what is a triangle and
you say well all those are triangles
well no we have to go
by the definition or the description
that
people made out there and the one we're
still using today are the ones uh
created by euclid okay he came up with
all these
so-called triangles okay or the
definition
and obviously you know he got that from
other greeks as well
right and so all these are not the same
so let me show you what the differences
are the first one is just an outline
just a bunch of dots
is that what it is just uh you know um
nothing in the center it's not a plane
it's just a line that
that went around is that what a triangle
is
or is the triangle the one on the side
which is the one
the dotted line but with a filled center
or the
filled whatsoever enclosed within the
boundary
and there's a difference between that
and the solid line
on the bottom the one on the bottom uh
the two
on the bottom actually uh have solid
lines these other guys are dotted lines
and so which one is it is it a dotted
line is it a segmented
line or are we talking about a solid
line
continuous line which of the two is the
triangle made of
well for this we got to look at the word
line because that's the word that's used
to define the triangle
okay let me get this one out
and uh here you see it
this is euclid's triangle this is how he
defined it
okay so that uh we find out that he did
it in terms of lines he says
a boundary is that which hasn't is an
extremity of of anything or something
from whatever
it figures that which is contained by
any boundary or
boundaries and again he's going to
consider whether triangle
is a figure instead of regular linear
figures right
are those which are contained by
straight lines
okay trilateral figures being those
contained by three
talking about a triangle of trilateral
figures uh
and equilateral triangles that which has
three sides and he goes into isosceles
scaling and so on okay fine so he's got
different types of triangles
and then he says for the dragon well he
just just goes over that again he just
talks about right angled and acute angle
triangles
so he just mentions different types of
triangles but what are they contained by
lines so we got to get down to the
bottom of this and find out what a line
is
okay because that's what he's going to
use to
uh encapsulate his triangle okay
so here it is um
well that's uh let me get uh euclid's
line
first okay here's euclid's line
okay and you can see uh the definition
he says
a line is breathless length okay
and uh what is the line the ends of
lines are points
and a straight line is what is a line
which lies evenly with the points
on itself what is the line made of
points
okay uh and uh by the way the modern
people have the same notions
line the set of points okay often
described in terms of two points
so what is a point well they tell you
it's a location
that's what a point is so a line is a
bunch of locations
every time they use the word line
they're talking about a bunch of
locations
there is no such notion as a continuous
line
a solid line a sign a line made of a
single piece
in all of modern or ancient geometry
the line is made of points what is a
point it's a location
that makes a line an itinerary so when
we're talking about a triangle a circle
or a square we're always talking about
itineraries
why itineraries because the
mathematicians what they do
is they measure they roll their they
unroll their measuring tape and they're
going to measure something
and so what they're what you're
essentially you're doing is
looking at the location of the front
side of your uh
measuring tape that you're unrolling
that's that's conceptually what's
happening with geometry
so they have no use for an object such
as
a circle or a square or a triangle
they can't do anything with that they
can't put the word triangle in an
equation and the word square in another
what they can put is a measurement of a
side of an angle or whatever
but they cannot put they cannot put a
plate like this yeah here's the circle
okay they can't put circle on the
equation what are they going to do with
this
they have no use for this for for
for the genuine circle
that belongs to geometry okay to the
plane
they have no use for that okay so um
here's the line
okay this is it it's an itinerary it's a
bunch of locations of the turtle
this is what it is but even if you don't
agree with me on that and you say well
maybe it's not just
uh maybe it's just a bunch of locations
static locations without any motion
okay so this is what you're saying
you're saying just a bunch of apples
you're just saying that each one of
those dots represents a location for
example of an apple
so it's either the one on the left or
the one on the right that's what a line
is and that's what they're gonna
encapsulate the triangle
with okay and i guess because they're
talking about
motion and they're not talking really
about locations and
motion and they're not talking at all at
all about a geometric
figure okay okay so
uh that's why the other day i covered
this uh
here's your famous circle okay circle is
an itinerary
circular itinerary okay here's the um
i can find it here this here's the
square yeah i showed the other day
yeah that's what they have that's what a
square is
square is just a bunch of locations of
an apple that's going around
some kind of perimeter or whatever okay
and uh so this takes us to our famous um
triangle okay guess what a triangle is
here it is you'll see it for the first
time
that's what a triangle is it's a bunch
of locations
it's a little dot which is uh
actually a representation of a location
it's a location of different locations
that's what it is they represent it with
a dot so that you can see something
and think that you're looking at a
figure right
and yes you can go in there and say well
what if we freeze those okay so that's
what you get
you get a triangle that's your triangle
and is that what a triangle is a bunch
of dots just a
perimeter nothing in in the center
because that's what a circle is said to
be okay
just a bunch of lines and lines are made
of points
so what are these people talking about
you know and and this is the issue the
issue is that
there are no geometric figures in
geometry they're all itineraries they're
all locations
and if if they're locations first it
doesn't belong in geometry to begin with
because
geometry is about shapes first and
foremost you have to have a shape
before you can do geometry just like you
have to have an object before you can do
physics
and they don't have objects and now you
can see where i'm coming from yeah
because they have all these
concepts out there they have black holes
what is that a singularity zero
dimensional singularity
and they think that's a geometric object
then they talk about space-time what is
space-time well it's uh
how they explain gravity what is gravity
it's
a geometric theory okay
why because they're saying it's the
shape of space-time so what is space
time is space time a physical object is
a geometric figure
no space time is a concept it's motion
space time they're talking about time
they're talking about motion
that's what they're talking about they
call that a geometric figure
and they talk about the geometric theory
of gravity
and that's what general relativity
supposedly is
that's how geometry entered the world of
physical interpretations which they call
mathematical physics
okay so this is this is where the
problem is the problem is that
all these uh so-called figures are not
figures what they are is itineraries
and because they started with
itineraries
they ended up with itineraries okay
and so what we have today is only
explanations
based on itineraries and we're missing
the objects we're missing the things the
figures
okay we don't have a mathematical
physics
theory uh based on objects
and we don't have as a result we don't
have actually
any physical interpretations all the
so-called physical interpretations
are concepts are motion in motion
locations in motion locations in
locations motions and motions
what is a wave wave is something already
in motion they talk about the movement
of a wave
the oscillating of a wave and when you
look at the wave there are a bunch of
vectors
and it's all like this all over
mathematical physics
you won't find a physical object that's
why these people eventually conclude
that you know light is not mediated by
an object
magnetism is not mediated by an object
gravity is not mediated by an object
right
because they can't see or touch it
and they're supposed to visualize it but
they don't worry about that because
mathematicians don't worry about
visualizations
they just want equations they want to
only describe
how the pencil fell
or or with what strength a magnet
attracts another
or how fast it went or whatever they're
not interested in the objects themselves
that's why we don't have physical true
genuine
physical interpretations in physics
today
okay okay so so much for the triangle
let's get on to some of the questions we
had out there uh
with uh other subjects here's one
fellow and he says uh again having to do
with experiments again
says if i successfully demonstrate
demonstrate transmutation surely that
should suffice to put the matter of
matter
to rest no no we don't do experiments
to prove matter what we do is we define
our terms so that we know what we're
talking about
before you can do an experiment you have
to do what is known as a design of
experiment
designing experiment you got to get your
language straight you got to know what
you're trying to accomplish
and so you design the experience say i'm
going to do experiment to try to show
this
but before you can do that you got to
design it you got to have the language
straight we don't have the language
straight then
what kind of what are you trying to
achieve and so we begin by defining what
an object is
that which has shaped what exists means
physical presence that's an object that
has location
and now we can get to the word matter
matter is an object that exists
okay usually uh a collection of objects
that exist
that's what matter means and so we don't
demonstrate
uh what matter is by def by uh running
an experiment now we do it through
definitions
in science in religion well we don't
know what they do in religion
another fellow along the same lines uh
he says um
and i think he was referring to this uh
a little uh picture that i showed the
other day which uh was uh by jim baggett
a so-called mathematical physicist
and uh what jim baggett said is you know
he says how does the electron go from
being almost everywhere to being here
you know
the wave function collapses suddenly you
know
and so he says how does it do that and
what he did was uh he put this dragon in
there
and i think this is what this fellow is
referring to he says the dragon
archetypes
physical allegory for for what you know
and this is the issue the issue is they
have no mediators in science
in so-called science and mathematical
physics okay
so-called physics uh they have no
mediators they do it with magic they
replace it with dragons they replace
with uh black magic with spirits with
angels
that's what mathematical physics all
over the planet
does all these so-called scientists all
these so-called
mathematical physicist they don't do it
with objects
so so what's between this a dragon
you know like you see there that's
what's they have no object
in there between the two magnets they
say this is done with magic or with
dragons or with angels
or spirits or whatever what is this done
with you know when this falls to the
floor
well it's done with magic also there's
no object coming in contact with the
skin of the pen
from above or below it just falls why
does it fall what
causes it to fall what came in contact
with the skin of the pen
they say nothing came in contact with
the skin of the pen
or they'll tell you a field and what
does it feel well we'll get to that in a
second i'm sure
i got a question on that as well okay
so these are type of questions that we
need
we don't have answers to because they
don't have physical interpretations
here's another fellow also on the issue
of experiments okay
and he says the following so so you're
saying that these nobel prize
winning scientists scientists i talked
about uh nobles
a while back a couple of months ago i
think are lying about their experiments
no i'm not saying they're lying i'm
saying that experiments have nothing to
do with science that's what i'm saying
so it doesn't matter what their
experiments say like i said a minute ago
because
an experiment does not give you a
physical interpretation that's a
separate issue
you know they can run all the
experiments they want on gravity in fact
all you need to run on gravity is one
experiment your entire life you let go
the pencil pulse of the floor
if you want to do it repeatable do it
two times you're done you that's
you did science now explain how mother
nature did that magic trick
and people do it with magic tricks they
do magic and so he says you haven't
presented any
what evidence to what proof
this is what people think you know proof
evidence experiments
the scientific experiment there is no
such monster as scientific
experiment experiment is has nothing to
do with science
okay science is explanation
150 explanation you have to explain
something that's when you have to use
the gray matter
but to run an experiment and let go of
the pencil and say oh i did an
experiment
i'm a scientist are you a scientist
because you did an experiment
you're a scientist because you found out
that two magnets come together and you
can say oh
oh i did an experiment is that science
science stops there you did an
experiment you're done oh hopefully
science is
trying to explain how mother nature does
that trick and
you're going to say there's no object
between or outside of the two magnets
or above and below the pencil in the
case of gravity
then you're introducing spirits you're
doing it with black magic
sorry but that's what you're doing okay
and again he talks about false pulses to
you
to you another guy is true you know so
true and
truth and false is a question of opinion
religion and again evidence experiment
and false so there's no need to answer
any of this because
you know a fellow thinks that uh
experiments and truth and false
improving have some
evidence have something to do with
science and so
yeah he has no clue what science is
about that's all religion all that stuff
experiment evidence proof convincing
persuading all that's religion
it's known as opinion okay
opinion and uh belief
another fellow says what says
experiments demonstrated the difference
between einstein and newton's
theories my god poor fellows
all these people really believe all this
nonsense they think that uh
some kind of experiment proved their
theories so let's correct him okay the
first thing we have to correct them is
that
neither einstein well i can't say
neither
but newton had no hypothesis he even
said i have no hypothesis fingo
non hypothesis he said and but he has an
equation an equation is a description a
description
is not a theory a theory is an
explanation
and that's what newton was saying when
he said he had no hypothesis
okay and einstein
same thing he says well he said he did
but he gave us the most irrational thing
he could come up with
he says the earth doesn't leave the
solar system because time is warped
it's a warp wall that stands in its way
that's how he explained that's his
theory
he's got an equation just like newton
equations our description so we don't
care about their equations
we want the bottom line why doesn't the
earth fly out of the solar system and
what einstein is telling you
is that time is warped and there's this
wall of warp
time and the earth cannot go beyond the
wall of warp time because it's the
wall of time which prevents the earth
from flying out of the solar system
and what they're saying is that the sun
is weighing down space
time it warps space
time and what they're saying is time is
warped
and that's why the earth doesn't fly out
so he's saying yes essentially that
there is
a wall of warp time that prevents the
earth from flying out that is his
physical interpretation
it is an irrational physical
interpretation
and so uh it doesn't belong in science
at all and the equation we don't care
about the equation equation is just a
description that that's not science
science is explanation not description
okay
and so uh you know you have to
understand that to understand what this
site is about
okay so no um
equations are not theories and here uh
we have
uh proof of what i just said for
einstein's theory
theory is an explanation of a mechanism
that's what a theory is
in the context of physics right newton
and einstein did
mathematical descriptions equations an
equation is not a theory
mathematics does not have a single
theory
okay mathematics is only a descriptive
language math is 100
descriptions now newton at least uh
offered no theory for how gravity works
but einstein proposed an irrational
physical interpretation
for how gravity works and here you have
on the one hand
mr uh brian green and there he says you
know
uh all these are his words by the way
it's the warping of space-time
okay that causes the moon not to fly out
of the earth
or the earth to fly out of the solar
system and another guy who's got like 68
million
um hits he he shows this
and people just gobble it up they say oh
that's science
so he shows a little ball rolling around
a
center there and the balls all fall in
there but it turns out that the earth
doesn't fall
to the sun neither does the moon towards
the earth and the question is
why does that ball fall if that's the
mechanism why don't we fall towards the
sun
and before we do that why doesn't the
ball fly away okay so
so again they're saying that this wall
of time
is what's preventing that ball from
going away i mean we can all
understand the trampoline there right
the uh the canvas
we all understand that because the
canvas that one there is a physical
object
but when you replace that canvas with
space time and you say that
space time is warped now you're warping
time and you're saying that the ball
rolls around
space time because time is warped
that's what they're saying and that is
an irrational theory because time is not
a physical object that would prevent
uh or impede you know the earth from
flying out of the solar system that's
where the irrationality comes in that's
not a physical interpretation
okay so uh yeah you won't get a rational
explanation from these people ever
okay uh fellow says
i like this one says uh two balloons are
filled
with exactly the same number of atoms
okay
one is filled with air and the other is
filled with helium
okay one falls to the ground yet the
other floats away
according to bill the number of
effective ropes are identical since the
number of atoms comprising the balloon
and the number of atoms filling the
balloons are the same
my god poor people
obviously this individual has
very little understanding of science of
chemistry especially okay
so i'll clarify it for people who have a
little more sense of this fellow
okay uh this fellow never figured out
that um
atoms are different they're atoms that
have different
uh atomic weight as it's known have more
protons and
uh neutrons and electrons and other
atoms there are differences in protons
neutrons and atoms
and electrons between atoms okay and so
let's show that okay and here on the
left hand side of that let me put it
over here on the side here
probably gonna be better okay um
you can see that the quantum atom
according to
people in quantum uh the
hydrogen atom has a little bead going
around the
proton bowling ball okay that's
that's their atom we don't know what
that purplish
area is because um
mr rutherford that says that's nothing
there's nothing there
other people say there's a field there
which is a concept a bunch of vectors
and so there's nothing we don't know
what's in there and that's the issue the
issue is
what physical object is between the
electron
and the proton that prevents the
electron from falling
to the nucleus remember one is negative
the other is positive and they should be
attracting each other
or the electron from flying away why
doesn't spontaneously fly away or fall
to the nucleus that's all they have to
answer
and that's the only question they can't
answer because that model is
ridiculous absolutely ridiculous
there's nothing sane about that atom
what does our atom look like well there
you see it on the
right and that's uh a membrane
that's encapsulating a star okay and
i've explained that in the past and i'm
going to go over that in
right now but what i want to show is
that helium is essentially four
hydrogen atoms it has uh two
hydrogen uh two uh protons in its center
and two neutrons according to the
quantum model
and two electrons on the outer side okay
and what
the way we build our atoms are again
with four
essentially um you can say hydrogen
atoms essentially it's two hydrogen
atoms and two
neutrons that neutrons has the neutron
has approximately the same amount of
matter
right the threads that make up each one
of these items are approximately the
same they have approximately the same
weight
okay same mass you want to call it that
way
okay so yeah we need four atoms hydrogen
atoms to make a helium
and each one of those has a separate
rope okay so
the helium atom has four ropes coming
out of it
and there you have oxygen oxygen has 16
hydrogen atoms essentially
and there you see the rope model
of the oxygen atom
the element oxygen and there you see the
configuration of that
okay you can see that it's got several
balloons and each balloon has a separate
rope
okay so this guy thinks that because we
have the same number of atoms uh we're
going to treat the
oxygen atom same as a helium atom same
as a hydrogen atom
and again it's because he doesn't know
the basics of chemistry okay
i guess he's never seen a a table of the
elements
and delay of table uh
yeah and turns out this guy tries to
define tangibility which is related to
the word object again
and so um he says define tangibility
here it is adjective capable of being
touched
you look at touchable which is what he's
saying it's uh tangible
tangibility so uh poor he doesn't know
how to define words
scientifically he never learned how to
he just copies
things from the dictionary within
without analyzing them just puts it in
there so i defined it
he didn't even understand what he put in
there and that's probably how he studied
if you can call that studying right
uh he studied just by memorizing and
just
regurgitating he never analyzed the
inside that
little thing that he's got in there um
he never analyzed what he was
reading but he was copying but he was
just transcribing
okay um here's uh
i think same fellow he tries to define
the word field
and uh it shows you something here about
him you know he says uh field
what is it um let me get this higher
here
uh field he says it's a region of space
okay
i'm sorry this is this is um let me get
his uh comment
give me a second here must have missed
it here
i think this is it
yeah well i don't know what i did with
his comment
but anyways uh fella said uh um
he's insisting that a field is a number
that's how it is
oh it is his uh issue because he says
the field is a region of space
and then he continues with a definition
of that but
he's saying it's a region that's what
he's saying and he says each point
of the region of space right each point
is associated with a quantity
so he's saying that it's a region of
space and he says it's a quantity a
bunch of quantities
so is a field a region or is it a bunch
of quantities
okay and he says the static field at any
given point
in space is a number and that's what the
good old nick uh curly uh nick lucid the
other day that we showed
um that's what he put up there he put a
bunch of numbers
uh x y coordinates then he's got a a
bunch of numbers in each one of those
essentially a
uh an ordered pair and and so
uh this is what they say is a field a
bunch of numbers
and okay so we don't know if it's a
region or if it's a bunch of numbers
okay it's one of those two apparently
they can't tell the difference
between a region and a bunch of numbers
quantities right
uh each one at each location in space i
don't know how you can put a number
in a location okay in space but then um
the interesting part is that the one on
the body said this number represents the
sodium and chloride
atoms okay and that's what i show on the
right uh
field a bunch of numbers and he's saying
that uh
that field the bunch of numbers
represents sodium and chloride
how a bunch of numbers or one number or
many numbers
represents an atom i don't know what he
means by that
what could a number how can a number
represent an atom
what sense does it make to say that but
let's find out if what he's saying has
any bit of rationality whatsoever
what he's saying is that all these
things all these fields
are numbers that represent
atoms and we gave the case uh example of
sodium and chloride here we have a
magnetic
field which is what we call whatever
stuff is between here
okay so is he saying that that field
is made of atoms that the numbers he's
going to put in there
in that region of say he's going to put
a bunch of numbers in there he says that
represents
atoms that's what he's saying so
are we saying that that's what's causing
this a bunch of atoms are pulling this
together
the field or pushing from the outside
is that is that how a magnet attracts
another through a field which is
a bunch of atoms is that what is above
and below this pencil when i drop it for
gravity
is there a field here a field here is
that what it is a
field a bunch of numbers which are just
atoms
is that what we have out there in space
pushing or pulling
on an astronaut when he's floating in
space the gravitational field is
made out of atoms is that what he's
saying when he says that
those numbers represent atoms
so this is the problem the problem is
these people don't know the difference
between an
object and a concept they they put a
concept they think they're talking about
object they say oh the field is made out
of
some kind of uh concept
that bunch of numbers vectors or
whatever
okay but let's uh here shows you
show you uh a magnetic field okay i want
you to look carefully at this because
here you can see it in slow motion
what is the uh magnet doing it's
attracting
one iron filing at a time in that region
around it
okay and what this guy is saying is
saying hey
what you have there is a bunch of
numbers and those
numbers represent atoms is that what's
attracting
each one of these iron filings are there
invisible atoms in that region that
attract the iron filings
or is there something else in there
and yeah with the uh with a an object
that you can't see or touch you can't
prove
what's in that region and so they said
there's nothing in there
and then they say well that nothing is a
bunch of atoms which
are represented by numbers that's what
this fellow is saying
so you know what have we learned with
him we learned what a field is with him
do we know what a field is by saying
it's a bunch of numbers that represent
atoms that we can't see or touch
is that what a field is great we learned
a lot
okay another common question here
fellow says you made an error of
interpretation aha
you said that in geometry the point is a
location
yeah that's what uh not what i say
that's what
everybody out there says except you
apparently okay
no in geometry the point is indefinite
whatever that means indefinite i mean i
guess he meant
undefined yeah undefined means that you
don't know what it is because we don't
define
geometric figures we point to them and
you can't point to a point
because there's nothing there to point
to because they say it's zero
dimensional because
it's a location that's why you can't
point to a point
because a point is not a geometric
figure
okay let's get that right because if
we're a figure would be at least two
dimensional
and that's what they put they put a dot
which is two dimensional perhaps three
in some cases depending on what
he's representing it with and uh then
they tell you
what you're staring at is zero dimension
it has no dimension
one staring at something that has two
dimensions at least
a dot it's got width and height and
they're saying well
you're not supposed to pay attention to
the dot the dot represents a location
just like this guy says
the field the vectors whatever uh
the numbers out there in space they
represent atoms
and this guy says something similar so
your whole subsequent interpretation
based on [ __ ]
from wikipedia is erroneous oh i'm sorry
okay in geometry line is an indefinite i
guess
he meant really undefined but i don't
know if that's what he meant
mathematical object no such monster as a
mathematical
object you know you we don't put
adjectives in
in front of the word object an object is
an object you have to define what an
object is now there are different
categories of object you have
two-dimensional objects
you have three-dimensional objects but
those are categories
object you have to define that word
before you can you
put an adjective in front and there's
certainly no such monster as
mathematical object
because that term has never been defined
mathematical objects so-called objects
are all
concepts not one is an object they call
them objects to give you the
misleading impression that they're
talking about physics that's the only
reason they put the word object in there
it is an abstractionism yeah which means
it's a concept
that's what all you said it is not a
moving point
well yeah it is um this follows
is really bamboozled by the um
by the establishment here's what it is
okay and this is not for me this is from
all these gurus out there first we have
euclid and he says a line is breathless
length
okay the ends of a line are points and a
straight line is a line which lies
evenly within what
the points on itself it's made out of
points
what are the uh bozos today of
mathematics say they say
line the set of points often described
in terms of what
two points example a b then you have the
concept of a point
captures the notion of what location
that's what you see on the bottom you
see a bunch of locations
and a bunch of locations is known as an
itinerary
that's what you're staring at point is a
location
and line is an itinerary what part don't
you understand
and that's from them you know i don't
use the word lion we don't have any use
for the word line and science
that's only in mathematics in geometry
in this religion called geometry
which attempts to merge math with
physics
impossible you can never merge
a description with an explanation two
different monsters and math is
describing physics is explaining
okay and final comment here uh rational
science according to bill
is explanation of the mechanism of how
mother nature works
well he's putting words in my mouth okay
that's i never defined it like that
i don't know where he got that okay in
my opinion this is not rational science
but rational physics well i don't know
uh so i want to clarify what i say
and not what this individual put in my
my
mouth okay uh he may have wanted to put
in his own words he did a lousy job no
let's say like it is uh rational science
is
rational explanations if we explain
phenomena
we're going to explain causes and
mechanism we're going to do that with
objects we need objects
that's known as physics okay so physics
is a branch of science because
rational science in general is rational
explanations whereas
physics is rational explanations of what
a phenomena
there has to be something happening
philosophy on the other hand is rational
explanations of
behaviors so we distinguish physics from
philosophy
okay but both of them belong to science
both of them
uh are rational explanations and you
have different
um uh what is it
you have different um disciplines within
each branch philosophy has history
has psychology and all that falls under
uh philosophy and then on the physics
side because they're going to explain
some behavior
you know why did napoleon go to waterloo
why did this guy
uh you know uh put drugs in his body or
whatever why did he eat this and instead
of that
so those are behaviors and so you're
looking at purpose
reason why someone did something that's
velocity physics deals with objects what
how something happened and by how i
don't mean a description i mean
how what what caused it to happen it's
uh
why but you got to be careful with the
house and wise
you have to apply them in the case of
physics to objects how
something happened means what caused it
to happen what triggered it to happen
okay that's what we mean when we say how
or why in physics
and uh so no i don't know what this
understood but
that's my definition of science and with
that i'll see you when
i'll see you on wednesday we'll see you
then bye-bye